At three years old, children have a hard time telling fantasy from reality. By five or six, they operate in both worlds. By the time they're 10, we expect children to be able to distinguish what's real from what isn't real. The process of becoming an adult, you could argue, is the process of learning to tell the truth about the world. But telling the truth is not always so easy.
三岁时，孩子很难分清幻想和现实。到了五六岁，他们开始在两个世界中游走。到了10岁，我们期望孩子能够区分什么是真实的，什么是虚构的。你可以认为，成长的过程就是学习如何面对世界真相的过程。但说实话并不总是那么容易。
When she was 10 years old, Claire switched schools, moved to a rich suburb. Her family didn't have much money. She became best friends with a girl whose family had immigrated from Chile. Claire started to become obsessed with her.
克莱尔10岁时转学去了富裕的郊区。她家没什么钱。她和一个家庭从智利移民过来的女孩成了最好的朋友，并开始对她着迷。
It wasn't really like when we would hang out together that I would idolize her, or that she was like the boss. But like, I'd go home and I would make up these songs about her, and I'd like make up songs about the letters of her name. She had like a really Spanish sounding name. And her phone number, I would just dial it over and over and over again. And I'd make songs about her phone number. Because it's just like everything about her was like golden to me. It was just like absolutely perfect and beautiful.
并不是说我们在一起玩时我就崇拜她，或者她是那种领头的人。而是我回家后会编一些关于她的歌，给她的名字里的字母编歌。她的名字听起来很有西班牙风格。还有她的电话号码，我会一遍又一遍地拨打，然后为她的电话号码编歌。因为关于她的一切对我来说都像金子一样珍贵。那简直是绝对的完美和美丽。
Claire dressed like the Chilean girl, wore only the modest jewelry that a Catholic mom would allow, demanded to go to Sunday School and get First Communion like the Chilean girl did. And then Claire started to tell people that she was Chilean herself. She'd say that her family fled a dictatorship, started over in America. That her family was like her friend's family.
克莱尔模仿那个智利女孩的打扮，只戴天主教母亲允许的朴素首饰，要求去主日学领圣餐，就像那个智利女孩做的一样。后来，克莱尔开始告诉别人她自己也是智利人。她说她的家人逃离了独裁统治，在美国重新开始。说她的家庭就像她朋友的家庭一样。
I think it was because she was really poor. Like my family was really poor. But she was like such a different kind of poor. You know, she was like the good, righteous poor. You know, it wasn't her fault or her family's fault that they were poor. It was like political oppression and circumstances that made them poor. And they were good, you know, people. And in my family, it was like there was violence and there was drinking and their family-- her mom kept a good house and my family always had like a really messy house. They just-- it wasn't her fault that she was poor. We were poor because we were bad people.
我想那是因为她真的很穷。像我家里就很穷。但她属于那种完全不同的穷。你知道，她是那种善良、正直的穷。你知道，他们贫穷不是她或她家人的错。那是政治压迫和环境造成的。他们是好人。而在我家，有暴力，有酗酒，她的妈妈把家里收拾得很整洁，而我家总是乱糟糟的。他们只是……她贫穷不是她的错。我们贫穷是因为我们是坏人。
Why do you lie? Sometimes you lie because you're powerless to do anything else. And who was more powerless than a 10-year-old child?
为什么你会撒谎？有时撒谎是因为你无力改变任何事。还有谁比10岁的孩子更无力呢？
It definitely carried me through that time. It definitely gave me a sense of like, a sense of pride. It's so weird, you know, that you can like feel pride in something that you're not. And there was just no other way except to lie about it. There were things that were just totally unmoveable and unchangeable. Which was, you know, because I was a kid and my family was the way it was. And there was nothing I could do about it.
那确实支撑我度过了那段时光。它确实给了我一种感觉，一种自豪感。很奇怪，你知道，你竟然会对一件你根本不是的事情感到自豪。除了撒谎之外别无他法。有些事情是完全不可动摇、无法改变的，因为我还是个孩子，我的家庭就是那样。我对此无能为力。
One summer, Claire went to a Bible retreat in Wisconsin with her mother and her brother. She befriended a girl from Venezuela. It was so natural, Claire says, you know, her being from Chile and all.
一个夏天，克莱尔和她妈妈、弟弟去威斯康星州参加了一个圣经静修会。她和一个来自委内瑞拉的女孩成了朋友。克莱尔说，这太自然了，你知道，毕竟她来自智利。
Yeah, so I told her that I was from there and that I didn't Spanish very well because I wasn't actually born there. That I came here when I was a baby or something, but that my family was from there. So obviously she was going to meet my mother and my brother, who spoke not a word of Spanish and didn't look at all, you know, Central or South American. But I remember hearing that like lots of Nazis moved down there and that, yeah, well, my mom, you know, she has blond hair and, you know, she looks the part, so yeah. That's what happened. And I kind of just decided that like my mom was a German descendant of a relative of some Nazi or something, and that that's where we were from. And that we moved back here because of political oppression.
是啊，所以我告诉她我来自那里，我西班牙语说得不好是因为我不是在那里出生的。我说我是婴儿时来到这里的，或者诸如此类的，但我的家人来自那里。所以很明显她会见到我妈妈和弟弟，他们一句西班牙语都不会说，看起来一点也不像中美洲或南美人。但我记得听说过很多纳粹搬到那里去了，而且我妈妈确实有金发，她看起来很像，所以就这样了。这就是发生的事情。我只是随口编了说我妈妈是纳粹亲属的德国后裔，我们因为政治压迫才搬回这里的。
This is how far it went. It was preferable for people to think that they were Nazis than to think they were low income people just living in a rich suburb of Chicago. And one of the most important things about these lies is that Claire says they didn't feel like lies at the time. She said she felt like she was telling people about a part of herself, a real part of herself.
事情发展到了这个地步。对她们来说，宁愿让人觉得她们是纳粹，也不愿让人觉得她们是住在芝加哥富裕郊区的低收入家庭。关于这些谎言，最重要的一点是，克莱尔说当时她并不觉得自己在撒谎。她说她感觉自己是在向别人讲述她自己的一部分，真实的一部分。
You know, if I could convince somebody else for just a little while then I could believe it, too.
你知道，如果我能说服别人哪怕一小会儿，那么我自己也能相信了。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, Truth and Lies at Age Ten. Today we bring you two stories about people lying to themselves, people lying because they thought they had no choice. And how they slowly came to face the truth, which took decades. Stay with us.
欢迎收听芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台联合制作的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天节目的主题是“10岁时的真相与谎言”。今天我们将讲述两个关于人们自我欺骗、因为觉得别无选择而撒谎的故事。以及他们如何慢慢面对真相，这花了他们几十年的时间。请继续收听。
Act One, I, Danny. How to deal with rejection. With something so primal as being told no. Being told you're not wanted here. You know, people spend years sometimes going over what happened, thinking it through, turning it over and over in their heads, wondering if they could have done anything differently. Trying to make sense of it. Well, Dan Gediman got a kind of cataclysmic rejection when he was a boy and, powerless to do much else, he lied about it. In this story he returns to the scene of the crime as much as you can and tries to make sense of what happened to him.
第一幕：我是丹尼。如何应对拒绝。面对像“不”这样原始的拒绝。被告知“这里不欢迎你”。你知道，人们有时会花几年时间反复思考发生的事情，在脑海里转来转去，想知道如果当初换种做法会怎样。试图理清思绪。丹·格迪曼在还是个男孩时遭遇了一种毁灭性的拒绝，在无能为力的情况下，他撒了谎。在这个故事里，他尽可能回到了“犯罪现场”，试图理解发生在他身上的事。
This is about a lie. A lie I tell almost to this day but not after this day. Anyway, I'm Dan Gediman. Danny. And I was in the first cast of the TV show Zoom. Chances are, Zoom is either something you've never heard of or something you can't forget. And it's probably the only TV show remembered for its address. Zoom was a public TV show for kids in the '70s, produced by WGBH in Boston and aired all over the country. For those of you who've never heard of Zoom , here's a little context from television historian David Kleeman.
这是一个关于谎言的故事。一个我至今几乎还在说的谎言，但过了今天就不会了。总之，我是丹·格迪曼。丹尼。我曾是电视节目《Zoom》的第一批成员。很可能，《Zoom》要么是你从未听说过的，要么是你永远无法忘记的。它可能是唯一一个因为邮政编码而被人们记住的电视节目。Zoom是70年代为孩子们制作的公共电视节目，由波士顿的WGBH制作，在全国播出。对于那些没听说过《Zoom》的人，电视历史学家大卫·克里曼会为你提供一点背景。
Zoom was really the first children's television program to put children at center stage, to tell them that their ideas, their works, their creativity was very important. It gave them a chance to submit ideas for the program, to submit art works, to submit pretty much anything that they thought was important in their lives. And then it might appear on the air. But one interesting thing about Zoom as a generational identifier, it's one of those programs where, if you walk up to people who are of that age, who did grow up with Zoom, and say the name, they'll sing the theme song back to you.
《Zoom》实际上是第一个将儿童置于舞台中心，告诉他们想法、作品和创造力非常重要的儿童电视节目。它给了他们提交节目创意、提交艺术作品、提交任何他们认为生活中重要事物的机会。然后这些可能会出现在电视上。但关于《Zoom》作为一代人的标志性符号，有趣的是，如果你走到那些长于那个年代、看着《Zoom》长大的同龄人面前说出这个名字，他们会为你唱出主题曲。
OK, here goes. [SINGING] Come on and zoom, zoom, zoom-a, zoom. Come on and zoom-a, zoom-a, zoom-a, zoom. We're gonna--
好了，开始。［唱］来吧，Zoom，Zoom，Zoom-a，Zoom。来吧，Zoom-a，Zoom-a，Zoom-a，Zoom。我们要——
I remembered constantly singing the theme.
我记得我一直在唱这首歌。
People who know it show great enthusiasm. They're willing to do the Bernadette Butterfly thing or risk singing the ZIP code.
知道它的人表现出极大的热情。他们愿意跳“伯纳黛特蝴蝶舞”或者冒险唱出那个邮政编码。
Boston, Mass., 02134. I still have it!
波士顿，马萨诸塞州，02134。我还没忘！
It was such a big part of my life and I remember-- like the first time I ever saw a kayak was on Zoom.
它是我生活中的重要部分，我记得……比如我第一次看到皮划艇就是在《Zoom》上。
And I was just dying to be friends with the kids on the show. Or be one of them.
我当时极度渴望和节目里的孩子们交朋友。或者成为他们中的一员。
[SINGING] Oh come on and zoom, zoom, zoom-a, zoom. We're gonna zoom-a, zoom-a, zoom-a, zoom.
［唱］噢，来吧，Zoom，Zoom，Zoom-a，Zoom。我们要Zoom-a，Zoom-a，Zoom-a，Zoom。
[INTERPOSING] That was as much a playground litany as "Ring Around the Rosies" for me growing up.
［插话］对于成长中的我来说，那就像“玫瑰花环”一样，是操场上的必唱曲。
02134. Yeah.
02134。是的。
02134. Send it to Zoom. You know, I haven't sung that in years. [SINGING] Come on and zoom. Come on and zoom, zoom. Come on and zoom.
02134。寄给《Zoom》。你知道，我已经好几年没唱过这个了。［唱］来吧，Zoom。来吧，Zoom，Zoom。来吧，Zoom。
OK. So, suffice it to say, for the purposes of this story at least, Zoom was a big deal. And if you were a cast member of Zoom, you were famous.
好的。总而言之，至少就这个故事而言，《Zoom》是个大事件。如果你是《Zoom》的成员，你就是名人。
Zoom was a given every week and I don't ever recall watching it with you, though. Now that I think about it. I don't recall ever watching that show with you. Maybe it was too painful. Did you watch it?
《Zoom》每周都会播，但我不太记得曾和你一起看过。现在想想，我不记得曾和你一起看过那个节目。也许那太痛苦了。你看过吗？
Yeah, I watched it.
是的，我看过。
That's my best friend, Adam. And he's right. It was painful. I guess I better tell you my lie now. I wasn't really on the first cast of Zoom . I was almost on the first cast of Zoom . They actually cast me and then they cut me. I can't tell you how horrible this was for a 10-year-old kid, but I guess I can try. That's what I'm doing here. Here's what happened, or at least what I think happened. Memory can protect you from the truth sometimes.
那是我的好朋友亚当。他是对的。那很痛苦。我想我最好现在就告诉你我的谎言。我其实并没有参加《Zoom》的第一季录制。我只是差点参加了。他们实际上选中了我，然后又把我裁掉了。我没法告诉你这对一个10岁的孩子来说有多可怕，但我会试着描述。这就是我在这的原因。这是发生的事，或者说至少是我认为发生的事。记忆有时会保护你免受真相的伤害。
I'm sitting in the dining room of my parent's house talking to my parents about Zoom. And I'm sitting around the dining room table.
我坐在父母家的餐厅里和他们谈论《Zoom》。我坐在餐桌旁。
To reconstruct my memory, I tried talking to my parents first.
为了重建我的记忆，我先试着和父母谈谈。
Now I think he told me that he liked certain qualities that you had, one of them was being very forthright.
现在我想他告诉我，他喜欢你具备的某些品质，其中之一就是非常直率。
Here's my dad, telling me what he recalls about how I talked to the Zoom producer, Chris Sarson, during the audition process.
这是我父亲在告诉我，关于我在面试过程中是如何与《Zoom》制作人克里斯·萨尔森交谈的。
But some of the things that you said, whether they ticked him off or not, I don't know. But the two I remember is, that you said that they were wearing rugby shirts and when he asked you what did you think of the rugby shirts, you said, they suck. That was what-- 12? How old were you? 10. Well, in those days that was very precocious. I don't know. Maybe it was popular then, too. In any case, I was embarrassed when I heard. Not because of the word, but just I thought, oh gee, there goes the farm.
但你说的某些话，不管有没有惹恼他，我不知道。但我记得的两件事是：你说他们穿着橄榄球衫，当他问你觉得橄榄球衫怎么样时，你说“烂透了”。那时候你多大？12岁？10岁。好吧，在那个年代这算是非常早熟。我不知道。也许那时这也挺流行的。总之，我听到的时候很尴尬。不是因为那个词，只是我想，噢天哪，一切都完了。
And the other one was the name of the show. And apparently you had told this Chris that you thought that Zoom was not a very good idea, that it was kind of corny or one thing or another. And you suggested, I don't know if you gave them another idea, but you suggested they change the name of the show. And those are two things I remember.
另一件事是关于节目的名字。显然你告诉那个克里斯，你认为《Zoom》这个主意不太好，觉得有点俗气之类的。你建议——我不知道你有没有给他们其他建议，但你建议他们改掉节目名字。这是我记得的两件事。
My father apparently remembers me as somewhat of a pain in the ass. And I suspect he's right. I was a bit of a-- shall we say-- a show-off. I certainly liked attention. I'd gotten the Zoom audition in the first place through a Sherlock Holmes skit that my dad, my brother, and I did around the family tape recorder.
我父亲显然把我记成了一个让人头疼的人。我怀疑他是对的。我确实有点——我们可以说——爱显摆。我当然喜欢受到关注。我最初拿到《Zoom》的试镜机会，是因为我爸、我弟和我围着家里的录音机演的一出福尔摩斯短剧。
Oh, Holmes! I'm John Alfafa, don't you remember me?
噢，福尔摩斯！我是约翰·阿尔法法，你不记得我了吗？
Of course, yes, I remember you very well from the club. Yes, yes, yes. How are you?
当然，记得，我在俱乐部见过你，印象非常深刻。是的，是的，是的。你好吗？
Very fine today. But I have a friend here that would like to meet you. Mr. Watson. Mr. John D. Watson.
今天非常好。但我有个朋友想见你。华生先生。约翰·D·华生博士。
I see, of course.
明白了，当然。
Yes, he's right here.
是的，他就这儿。
Of course, you neglected to mention that it's Dr. John D. Watson.
当然，你忘了说那是约翰·D·华生博士。
Oh, hello, Mr. Holmes. I'm Dr. Watson.
噢，你好，福尔摩斯先生。我是华生博士。
Of course you're Dr. Watson. John D. Watson.
你当然是华生博士。约翰·D·华生。
It looked like it was all set. I think that I'm sure that I was telling everybody that you were going to be in it. And this was the very beginning of Zoom , so it was going to be the very first group.
看来一切都定了。我想我肯定告诉所有人你会参加录制的。那是《Zoom》刚开始的时候，所以那是第一组。
Do you recall at all my excitement about this? I remember being in the kitchen, right around where the sink is, and it was at night, and I was having a little fantasy in my head about what type of house to buy you. OK. What type of house I would buy you with the-- in my mind-- the millions of dollars that were going to be coming in from doing this show. I was sort of imagining, you know, different styles of houses. And you were going to be so proud of me because I was going to move you into this house, like Elvis did with his parents.
你还记得我当时有多兴奋吗？我记得在厨房里，就在水槽附近，那是晚上，我在脑海里幻想该给你买什么样的房子。好吗？我要用我脑子里想的——做这个节目赚来的几百万美元给你买什么样的房子。我在想象各种风格的房子。你会为我感到骄傲，因为我会把你接进这所房子，就像猫王为他父母做的那样。
So this wasn't just a case of me wanting to be famous. I wanted the money, too. I thought I was going to be like Jodie Foster or Johnny Whitaker, from A Family Affair.
所以这不仅仅是我想要出名。我也想要钱。我以为我会成为像朱迪·福斯特或《家庭事务》里的约翰尼·惠特克那样的人。
My dad had been laid off from his engineering job and our family was coming out of some pretty hard times in the early '70s. Or at least it seemed that way to me at age 10. I thought I could save them. I was banking on it. But then it fell apart. And this is where it gets hazy. I know I invented some stories to protect myself. But now I can't exactly remember which ones. And my parents couldn't help.
我父亲被工程师职位裁掉了，我们在70年代初度过了一段非常艰难的时期。至少在10岁的我看来是这样。我以为我能拯救他们。我把筹码都压在这上面了。但随后一切都破灭了。这就是变得模糊的地方。我知道我编了一些故事来保护自己。但现在我不确定具体是哪些。我父母也帮不上忙。
So I decided to embark on a search for the truth about my past. Even though it had been 25 years, I figured, what the hell. I'd contact the members of that first cast of Zoom .
所以我决定开启一段寻找过去真相的旅程。尽管已经过了25年，我想管他呢。我要联系《Zoom》第一季的成员们。
I continued to be recognized up till my third year in college. I was registering at NYU, and I was stopped at the front door by someone who recognized me.
直到大学三年级我还在被认出来。我在纽约大学注册时，被一个认出我的人在门口拦住了。
That's John. I called him up in New York, where he's a playwright now and approaching middle age, like all of us. This is him 25 years ago.
那是约翰。我给在纽约的他打了电话，他现在是个剧作家，像我们所有人一样步入中年。这是25年前的他。
She cannot read, read, read. She cannot write, write, write. But she can smoke, smoke, smoke her father's pipe. She asked her mother, mother, mother for fifty--
她不会读，读，读。她不会写，写，写。但她会抽，抽，抽她父亲的烟斗。她问她的母亲，母亲，母亲要五十……
I thought John could shed some light on my history because he was part of the reason, at least as I remember it, that Chris, the producer, cut me from the cast.
我以为约翰能为我的历史揭示一些真相，因为按照我的记忆，克里斯（制作人）把我裁掉，原因至少有一部分与他有关。
And then Chris Sarson told me, I'm afraid we've decided internally that we need to add another girl to the cast.
然后克里斯·萨尔森告诉我，恐怕我们在内部决定需要增加一名女孩到阵容中。
Oh.
噢。
And there's too many-- we had five boys and two girls. Nina and Nancy. And what Chris told me was that you and John are both sort of little song and dance men. And so we've just sort of arbitrarily decided that John would work out better than you.
那时人太多了——我们有五个男孩和两个女孩。妮娜和南希。克里斯告诉我的是，你和约翰都是那种唱歌跳舞的小能手。所以我们只是草率地决定约翰比你更适合。
I can't believe they said that! I cannot believe they said that. Oh my god.
我真不敢相信他们会这么说！我不敢相信他们会说出这种话。天哪。
And then said to me, but, but, but we're going to roll the cast over in a few months and bring in new kids. And we would like you to be involved then. But my recollection is that I turned down the opportunity to be on the second cast out of youthful hubris.
然后又对我说，我们会在几个月后重新调整阵容，加入新孩子。我们希望那时候你能参与。但我的记忆是我出于年轻时的傲气拒绝了这个机会。
Really?
真的吗？
I felt so humiliated. So-- so I--
我感到非常受辱。所以我……所以我……
You can like title this piece, like Misery.
你可以把这段作品命名为《痛苦》。
Well, I think I felt like, you know, I had my shot. I blew it. I'm no good. Why bother?
好吧，我想我当时觉得机会已经错过了。我搞砸了。我不行。何必呢？
Yeah, all at age 10. Your life is over at age 10.
是啊，都是10岁时的事。10岁时你的人生就结束了。
John was sympathetic and I appreciated that. But he didn't remember any of this incident. And no reason he should, I suppose.
约翰表示了同情，我很感激。但他完全不记得这件事了。我想，他没理由记得。
Why don't you go ahead and open up the package I gave you?
你为什么不把那个包裹打开？
He and I were in different studios for this interview and I'd sent him a photo that he opened while we were talking on the phone to see if he even remembered me.
我和他在不同的演播室进行这次采访，我给他寄了一张照片，他在电话里聊的时候打开了，看看他是否还记得我。
Oh. Oh my goodness. Wow. Oh, look how little we are. Holy smokes. Now this really brings back how young we were. Oh. Now this is you with the blond hair? Oh, man.
噢。噢，天哪。哇。噢，看看我们有多小。天哪。这真的勾起了我们当时有多年轻的回忆。噢。这是留金发的你吗？噢，伙计。
Does it ring any bell whatsoever?
这勾起任何一点回忆了吗？
In your suit. Mmmm.
穿着西装的你。嗯……
I'll take that as a no.
我就当那是没印象了。
Yeah, it really-- you know, I feel, I'm embarrassed. You look like you're a really cute kid. You should have been there.
是啊，真的……你知道，我感到很尴尬。你看起来是个很可爱的孩子。你应该在那里的。
I'm Joe.
我是乔。
I'm Nina.
我是妮娜。
I'm Kenny.
我是肯尼。
My name's Tracy.
我叫特雷西。
I'm Tommy.
我是汤米。
I'm Nancy.
我是南希。
I'm John.
我是约翰。
I still have paycheck stubs from back then. I saved them.
我还有当年的工资单，我留着它们。
Next I went to visit Joe, another kid from the first cast.
接下来我去找了第一季的另一个孩子，乔。
And all the publicity. God, we were in-- we must have been in every single newspaper in the United States. We were in Life magazine, Time magazine.
还有所有的宣传。天哪，我们肯定上了美国每一份报纸。我们上了《生活》杂志、《时代》周刊。
Just what I wanted to hear.
这正是我想要听到的。
It was a great experience. An amazing experience. It's on my CV. Absolutely. I put it on my CV now when I apply for jobs as a psychiatrist.
那是一次很棒的经历。一次惊人的经历。它在我的简历上。当然。我现在申请精神科医生职位时也会把它写上。
Now Joe is a child psychiatrist. Isn't that perfect? I remember Joe as a nice kid. Very magnetic, thoughtful.
现在乔是一名儿童精神科医生。这难道不完美吗？我记得乔是个好孩子，很有魅力，思维缜密。
I just remember you were blond and you were fun. And it seemed a good fit. I was convinced that you were on the show. I think we all were. But you know, I guess then we never got together after that, did we?
我只记得你是金发，而且很有趣。看起来很合适。我曾确信你参加了那个节目。我想我们大家都确信。但你知道，我想后来我们就没在一起过，对吧？
No, we didn't. Not until now, all these years later. Talking to Joe, it was like I couldn't help myself, him being a psychiatrist and all. I began to confess.
没，没有。直到这么多年后的现在。和乔交谈时，我忍不住向他坦白，毕竟他是位精神科医生。
All the kids in my school, I remember them making announcements over the PA system that I was on Zoom . And I was treated, for a brief period of time, from being rather a pariah, to being a celebrity. And then back again, lower, because the kids felt like I had, you know, lied or something. And the year after my whole Zoom deal was really rough. And since then, I'm sure I went through a period where I told some fibs about my experience. If only because it was so humiliating, in my mind, what really happened.
我记得学校里所有的孩子都在广播系统里宣布我参加了《Zoom》。在很短的一段时间里，我从某种被排斥的状态变成了名人。然后又掉落下来，因为孩子们觉得我撒谎了什么的。那一整年我的《Zoom》经历真的很糟。从那以后，我肯定有过一段时期，因为这段经历在我的心目中太丢人了，所以我编了一些关于这段经历的谎话。
You've obviously grown quite a bit. It's to your credit. You must have a good therapist. You know, I think that you actually, of everybody involved in Zoom , probably had the most unique experience. And I can see it as a really devastating experience.
你显然成熟了很多。这是你的功劳。你一定有一位很好的治疗师。你知道，我认为在所有参与《Zoom》的人中，你可能有最独特的经历。我能理解这是一种非常有毁灭性的体验。
Listen. He's treating me.
听着，他在治疗我。
I mean, there you are. You're given the prize and then they say, I'm sorry, you're disqualified. This is tough for anybody, but especially at that age. I mean, your whole self esteem is mixed into this. There you are. Are you good? Aren't you good? Are you talented? Aren't you talented? What is this? You know, I'm not the right sex? If I was a girl I would be able to do this? So I think, you know, I don't envy your position. This is a tough position to be in. It's a tough experience to have had.
我的意思是，奖项摆在那里，然后他们告诉你：抱歉，你被取消资格了。这对任何人来说都很艰难，更不用说在那个年龄了。你的整个自尊都与此息息相关。我在那儿。我优秀吗？我不优秀吗？我有天赋吗？我没天赋吗？这是怎么回事？我是性别不对？如果我是女孩我就能做到吗？所以我认为，我不羡慕你的处境。这确实是一个艰难的位置。这是一段艰难的经历。
Joe told me that maybe I've been recreating this past in my relationships, where I might be loved by someone but I'm always thinking that they could change and decide, no, I don't want to love you. And I told them about how I had one set of memories in which I was the one who told Zoom that I didn't want to be a part of it.
乔告诉我，也许我在人际关系中一直在重演这段过去，我可能会被某人爱，但我总是在想他们随时会改变主意，决定“不，我不想要爱你了”。我告诉他，我曾有一段记忆，记忆里是我自己告诉《Zoom》我不想参加的。
My guess is if you created this memory where you blew off Zoom instead of the other way around you might have been just a tad on the angry side, don't you think? Just a little annoyed by this whole event. But it's an incredible experience that you had. That needs to be cherished. It is unique. I didn't have that. Thank god.
我猜，如果你创造了这种记忆，比如是你主动放弃了《Zoom》而不是相反，你可能只是有点生气，对吧？对整个事件感到一点恼火。但这确实是一段不可思议的经历。需要珍惜。这是独一无二的。我没有过那样的经历。谢天谢地。
Listen, I know time is up. I had two things I was hoping to do before I walked out the door. One of which-- you probably aren't asked this very often. I'm wondering if you could autograph your picture here. I'm going to ask Tommy to do the same.
听着，我知道时间到了。我在离开前有两件事想做。其中之一……你可能不常被这样要求。我想知道你能不能在这张照片上签名。我也要请汤米做同样的事。
Listen to me. I'm getting his autograph. Why? Because he's famous. He's Joe, the Zoom kid.
听着，我正在得到他的签名。为什么？因为他是名人。他是乔，《Zoom》男孩。
Well, I mostly remember speaking to you on the phone, like often during that period, I guess. And you were kind of a wise-cracking, kind of show-bizzy, kind of person that I seem to get along with pretty well. As I do gravitate toward show-biz phonies even now.
嗯，我大多记得那段时间经常和你通电话。你是一个那种爱说俏皮话、有点演艺圈气息的人，我和你相处得不错。正如我现在依然偏爱演艺圈的势利眼一样。
That's Tommy, another Zoomer from the first cast. He was actually my best friend of that group. We talked all the time on the phone while we were auditioning for the show.
那是汤米，第一季的另一个“Zoomer”。他其实是我在那组里最好的朋友。我们在为节目试镜时经常通电话。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
［重叠的说话声］
Then dip your note in a bucket of lard.
然后把你的纸条浸在猪油桶里。
In a bucket of lard, yeah.
在猪油桶里，是的。
Then Nancy came in.
然后南希进来了。
Joe doesn't know what he's talking about. You put it in an envelope, without a doubt.
乔根本不知道他在说什么。毫无疑问，把它放在信封里。
Then everybody came in.
然后大家都进来了。
Then take your typewriter, pencil, or pen. If you make a mistake, you gotta do it again.
然后拿起你的打字机、铅笔或钢笔。如果你犯了错，你得重写一遍。
I got a real kick out of reminiscing like this. It made me feel like I was still part of things somehow. Tommy really tried to make me feel better. He called me the Pete Best of Zoom , which didn't really help that much, but I knew his heart was in the right place. But what I wanted to know from him was, was it great being a Zoom kid? What did I miss? Was it great being famous?
我从这样的回忆中得到了真正的乐趣。它让我觉得我在某种程度上仍然是其中的一部分。汤米真的试图让我感觉好些。他称我为《Zoom》的皮特·贝斯特（Beatles的落选成员），这其实没什么大用，但我知道他是出于好意。但我真正想知道的是，做一个《Zoom》的孩子感觉很好吗？我错过了什么？出名感觉很好吗？
Well, I'm sure that the fame must have went to my head because you've got so many people walking around kissing your ass and telling you how great you are. And just the fact that you're on TV, people look up to you. Just the fact that you're on TV is always like one of the biggest things you can do in America. It doesn't matter how-- what kind of other achievements you can get.
嗯，我肯定那名气冲昏了我的头，因为有那么多人围着你奉承你，告诉你你有多棒。只要你上了电视，人们就会仰望你。单单“你上了电视”这一点，在美国就是你能做的最大的事情之一。不管你还能获得什么样的其他成就都不重要。
Tommy and some of the others from that first Zoom cast went on to try to make it big. They did a commercial TV show and a record, but nothing really panned out.
汤米和《Zoom》第一季的其他一些成员后来试着想要大红大紫。他们做了商业电视节目和唱片，但都没有成功。
Our parents kind of kept the ball rolling and we got like a lounge band and tried to play live, and then things just kind of started fizzling. When things start fizzling down, they fizzle down pretty quick.
我们的父母负责运作这些，我们组建了一个休息室乐队，尝试过现场演奏，然后事情就开始慢慢熄灭了。当事情开始平息时，它们消失得很快。
Tommy's a video cameraman now. He loves the work, but he still wants to be a rock star. In fact, he gave me a compilation tape of all the bands he's been in over the years, hoping I might use it on this show.
汤米现在是一名摄像师。他热爱工作，但仍想成为摇滚明星。事实上，他给了我一盘他多年来参与的所有乐队的合辑磁带，希望我能在节目中使用。
The long term effects of this on you, you know. Looking back now, you're 30-- 9? Is that right? OK. It's been 25 years. How has being a Zoom kid affected you long-term?
这事对你的长期影响，你知道的。回顾现在，你39岁了？对吗？好的。已经25年了。作为《Zoom》男孩的经历对你有什么长期影响？
It created my dream to work in this business. A dream that I pursue to this day. So it was a very heavy influence. It's hard to live up to it sometimes. You're really hard pressed to come up with something that's a better, well-known achievement than that. I don't care how many degrees you have, how good you are, or how smart you are. If you're on Zoom , that's what people know you from. So I'll just accept that fact and move on.
它创造了我从事这个行业的梦想。一个我至今仍在追求的梦想。所以这是一个非常重大的影响。有时很难达到那个高度。你真的很难想出一个比那更著名、更有成就感的案例。我不在乎你有多少学位，你有多优秀，或者你有多聪明。如果你上过《Zoom》，那就是人们认识你的原因。所以我只会接受这个事实，然后继续前进。
Kind of depressing. I confess it made me feel a little better though. When I got home from talking to Tommy, I listened to his tape.
有点压抑。我承认这让我感觉好了一点。从汤米那里回家后，我听了他的磁带。
Once you've done it, it debunks the mystique. Because in real life terms, what it meant was you really couldn't walk down the street without being recognized in some way or scrutinized.
一旦你做到了，它就打破了神秘感。因为在现实生活中，这意味着你真的无法走在街上而不被认出或被审视。
This is John again.
这是约翰再次发言。
There were certain events that were sort of traumatizing, like being mobbed. When a year ago, you could go to the mall and just buy your shoes or whatever, I'm with friends and suddenly, hey, there's John. And then three more, three people come and of course, will you sign? Then someone decides, oh, it's a good idea to get an autograph. And suddenly you can't move because they're-- it's what seems like a multitude. Who knows? Probably it was 20 people. They're demanding your time. They're grabbing your arm. I found it incredibly unpleasant. Because they're looking-- they were looking at me and not seeing me. They were seeing some sort of image. And it was sort of a glazy look of excitement and unreality.
有一些事件是有点令人创伤的，比如被围攻。一年前你还可以去商场买鞋，我和朋友在一起，突然，“嘿，那是约翰”。然后又是三个人，当然还有“能签个名吗？”然后有人觉得，“噢，去拿个签名是个好主意”。突然你动弹不得，因为——看起来有好多人。谁知道呢？可能只有20个人。他们占用了你的时间。他们拽你的胳膊。我发现这极其令人不愉快。因为他们看着我，却并没有看到我。他们看到的是某种图像。那是一种兴奋和虚幻的呆滞眼神。
This kind of helped, hearing this. I began to wonder if maybe I missed something that wasn't so great after all. Whether I wasted a lot of time wishing I was on the show, even pretending sometimes that I was.
听到这些很有帮助。我开始怀疑，我是不是错过了一些其实没那么好的东西。我是不是浪费了太多时间希望自己能上那个节目，甚至有时假装自己上了。
You know what? I want to ask you a question. I want to ask you if it was true, were you ever really going to be on Zoom?
你知道吗？我想问你一个问题。我想问你，如果那是真的，你真的曾经要上《Zoom》吗？
Yes.
是的。
I called up Karen. She had nothing to do with Zoom , she just watched it. But she was one of my closest friends during that time.
我给凯伦打了电话。她和《Zoom》没什么关系，她只是看过而已。但她是那段时间我最亲密的朋友之一。
I've come to distrust some of my own memories and wonder whether, you know, how much of it was wishful thinking. How much of it was fantasy or dreams or aspirations. And/or what I told people as sort of a cover story.
我开始怀疑自己的一些记忆，想知道有多少是自欺欺人。有多少是幻想、梦想或抱负。和/或我作为某种掩盖故事告诉人们的内容。
I guess I should get back to my lie, in the spirit of full disclosure. Here's exactly what my lie was. I let people believe that I, Dan Gediman, was Danny. The Danny. The real Danny on Zoom .
我想我应该回到我的谎言，本着完全披露的精神。我的谎言完全是这样的：我让人们相信我，丹·格迪曼，就是丹尼。那个丹尼。《Zoom》上那个真正的丹尼。
Was there a kid on the show named Danny?
节目里有个叫丹尼的孩子吗？
Yes.
是的。
And I remember trying to make him be you. Because I wanted you to be on that show so much. I though, well, maybe that's Danny. Maybe he just looks very different on television, and sounds different.
我记得我试图让你成为他。因为我太希望你上那个节目了。我想，嗯，也许那就是丹尼。也许他在电视上看起来很不一样，声音也不一样。
He was actually in the second cast. I didn't really intend to impersonate him or anything, but some of the time I would just kind of go with it and say, yeah, I was Danny. Which, technically speaking, was true. And they would get all excited and think that they were with a celebrity. So I did get some mileage out of that.
他其实是在第二季。我并没有真的打算冒充他，但有时我只是顺水推舟说“是的，我是丹尼”。从技术上讲，这是真的。他们会很兴奋，以为自己遇到了名人。所以我确实从中获得了一些好处。
Oh, I was totally impressed.
噢，我当时完全被震惊到了。
This is my friend, Angela.
这是我的朋友安吉拉。
Yeah, I couldn't believe I knew somebody who had actually been on Zoom . It would be like knowing, you know, the guy who did Oscar the Grouch or something. But then I was very sorry to hear that you were kicked off. I think you would have made a fine Zoomer. Actually, I think-- oh, I know what my response was. My response was, you weren't Danny, were you? That's what it was. Now, if that had been the case I don't know what I would have done.
是的，我不敢相信我认识一个真正上过《Zoom》的人。那就像认识演《芝麻街》奥斯卡那个家伙一样。但后来我听到你被踢出节目感到很遗憾。我想你会是个很棒的Zoomer。其实，我知道我的反应是什么了。我的反应是：“你不是丹尼，对吧？”就是这样。如果当时真是那样，我不知道我会怎么做。
If I'd really been Danny?
如果我真的是丹尼？
If you'd really been Danny, I'd-- you know, it'd probably be almost like-- not quite-- well, it wouldn't exactly be like meeting Donny Osmond. But it would have been up there, I would say. Yeah.
如果你真的是丹尼，我会——你知道，那可能就像——也不完全是——好吧，那不会完全像见到唐尼·奥斯蒙德。但我会说，那也会相差无几。是的。
So you were disappointed when you found out--
所以当你发现时你很失望——
I wasn't disappointed. But you know, it was a nice little thought there for a moment, that maybe you might have actually been him.
我不失望。但你知道，那一刻有一个美好的小念头，也许你真的可能就是他。
You know, I think everyone I talked to really wanted to make me feel better. It's OK that you weren't the real Danny. You're a perfectly good Danny. By the way, do you know the real Danny? See, that's the problem, isn't it? Fame makes you more real. And it's funny, we protect children from other adult experiences that have this kind of power, but not from this one. We don't let them drive cars or smoke or get married, but we let some of them be famous, and the other ones yearn for it.
你知道，我觉得我交谈过的每个人都真的想让我感觉好些。你不是真正的丹尼也没关系。你是个很棒的丹尼。顺便问一下，你认识真正的丹尼吗？看，这就是问题所在，不是吗？名气让你变得更加真实。有趣的是，我们保护孩子免受其他具有这种权力的成人经历的影响，但不包括这个。我们不让他们开车、抽烟或结婚，但我们却允许其中一些人成名，而另一些人则渴望成名。
And here's something else. WGBH is starting the whole thing up again. They're reviving Zoom right now. They have a new cast, a new director. It's already hitting the airwaves in some markets.
还有一件事。WGBH正在重新开始这一切。他们正在复活《Zoom》。他们有了新演员、新导演。在某些市场上它已经开始播出了。
Back when our parents were young, they had the first interactive show for kids. That was then and this is now! A brand new Zoom. It's hip, it's hot, and it's for our generation.
早在我们父母年轻时，他们就有过第一个互动儿童节目。那已经是过去，现在是现在！全新的Zoom。它很潮，很热，是属于我们这一代的。
So I went back to Boston and dropped by. I wanted to see the new kids, imagine their futures, guess at their fame.
所以我回到了波士顿顺便去看看。我想看看这些新孩子，想象他们的未来，猜测他们的名气。
What happened when you were finally told, all right, you're in?
当你最终被告知“好吧，你入选了”时，发生了什么？
Well, I was at my friend's house and my mom called me. I answered the phone and she said, Haley, you're in Zoom, and I was screaming so loud. My friends started screaming. They didn't know what they were screaming about. Then when I came home, everybody was jumping up and down in the driveway. So that was fun.
嗯，我在朋友家，我妈给我打电话。我接起电话，她说：“海莉，你入选《Zoom》了”，我尖叫得很大声。我的朋友们也开始尖叫。他们都不知道自己在尖叫什么。后来当我回家时，每个人都在车道上跳来跳去。那很有趣。
Have you thought at all about when it happens-- when I was your age and I was going through this, I gave a lot of thought to, oh my god, I'm going to be famous. You know? Have you thought at all about what it would be like to be famous?
你有没有想过当这件事发生时——我像你这么大的时候，我正在经历这个，我想了很多，“噢天哪，我会出名的”。你知道吗？你有想过出名是什么样子吗？
Yes. That'd be awesome. And if I did become famous, I'd try out for tons more stuff. But I don't really care about being famous. I just like-- I've been in plays. And it's no different from being in like any TV show. I just like it because it's fun, and I like to do this kind of stuff. But that'd be awesome if I was famous. I'm Haley!
是的。那会很棒。如果我真的出名了，我会尝试更多的东西。但我并不真正在意出名。我只是……我参加过戏剧。这和参加任何电视节目没区别。我喜欢它只是因为有趣，我喜欢做这些事情。但如果我出名了会很棒。我是海莉！
Awesome. Yeah. Like Danny. The real Zoom Danny, who I finally tracked down in Marlborough, Massachusetts, where he's working now as a musician. I called him up.
太棒了。是的。就像丹尼。真正的《Zoom》丹尼，我最终在马萨诸塞州的马尔伯勒找到了他，他现在是一名音乐家。我给他打了电话。
[SINGING] Come on and zoom. Come on and zoom, zoom. Come on and zoom. Come on and zoom, zoom.
［唱］来吧，Zoom。来吧，Zoom，Zoom。来吧，Zoom。来吧，Zoom，Zoom。
How's that?
那样怎么样？
That sounds great.
听起来很棒。
Thanks. Great song.
谢谢。很棒的歌。
I have spent almost 25 years, since my own involvement briefly with Zoom , being mistaken for you.
自从我本人短暂地参与《Zoom》以来，我花了近25年的时间被误认为是你们。
No.
不。
My name is Danny. You've never seen me, but I have-- when I was the age-- we're about the same age. And I had long, blond hair down to my shoulders. Thick Boston accent, it's gone now. And we actually resembled each other a little bit. So as my teen years progressed, I would oh, meet somebody, often a member of the opposite sex, and I would start to tell them the story of how I almost got on Zoom , and they would look at me, and they would kind of size me up. And they'd say, you're Danny. I remember you. You're Danny.
我叫丹尼。你从没见过我，但我有——当时我——我们的年纪差不多大。我留着长长的金发，垂到肩膀。浓重的波士顿口音，现在没了。我们确实看起来有点像。所以随着青春期的到来，我会……遇到某人，通常是异性，我会开始告诉他们我差点上《Zoom》的故事，他们会看着我，打量我一番。然后他们会说：“你是丹尼。我记得你。你是丹尼。”
That's funny.
那很有趣。
And I have to be honest with you, I did not always correct them.
我必须对你说实话，我不总是纠正他们。
That's great. That's funny.
太棒了。那很有趣。
OK. I confessed. I'll skip over this part, but basically Danny was nice about it. Maybe a little embarrassed for me. Maybe a little flattered. Like Tommy, he sent me a tape of the band he's in, just in case I wanted to use it in this show. Here it is, by the way.
好的。我坦白了。我会跳过这一部分，但基本上丹尼对此很友好。也许为我感到有点尴尬。也许有点受宠若惊。像汤米一样，他寄给了我一盘他乐队的磁带，以防我想在节目里用它。顺便说一句，就是这个。
I told Danny about my friend Angela and how she was in love with him, second only to Donny Osmond. And he was flattered by that. So I asked him a favor, to say hi to her. To give her kind of a radio autograph.
我告诉了丹尼关于我的朋友安吉拉的事，以及她有多迷他，仅次于唐尼·奥斯蒙德。他对此感到受宠若惊。所以我请他帮个忙，向她问好。给她一种广播签名。
If we could take 15 seconds, we would make this woman's day. She's now in her early 30s. And just send a message out there to Angela.
如果我们能花15秒钟，就能让这个女人的这一天变得完美。她现在30出头了。向安吉拉传达一个信息。
Hi Angela, this is Danny from Zoom , and I heard you were my biggest fan. It's great to get an opportunity to thank you for watching Zoom and being a fan of mine. That means a lot to me. And I do get around. If you're ever up in the Boston area, look me up and it'd be great to get together and say hi in person. Take care and best of luck to you.
嗨安吉拉，我是《Zoom》的丹尼，我听说你是我的超级粉丝。很高兴有机会感谢你观看《Zoom》并成为我的粉丝。这对我意义重大。我会经常走动。如果你在波士顿地区，找我，我们见个面打个招呼会很棒。保重，祝你好运。
See how his voice sounds? He knows he's the real Danny, that he can improvise a long paragraph like that to a complete stranger, a stranger who he assumes would want to look him up if they ever came to town. And in fact, he's probably right. He did it. He was a Zoomer. It's part of him. Like Joe the psychiatrist says.
看到他的声音了吗？他知道他是真正的丹尼，他可以对一个完全的陌生人即兴说出这样长的一段话，一个他假定如果来到城里就会想要找他的陌生人。事实上，他可能是对的。他做到了。他是Zoomer。这是他的一部分。正如精神科医生乔所说。
It satisfied a very important part of my life, you know, that sense of having had that fame, having had that sense of being somebody special. And I don't need to do that anymore. It's nice. You've just got to go on.
它满足了我生命中非常重要的一部分，你知道，那种拥有名气、拥有那种作为一个特别的人的感觉。我不需要再做那个了。这很好。你只需要继续前进。
Do you remember me at all?
你还记得我吗？
Oh, sure. I don't remember your audition, and I don't remember-- although I certainly hope when I open the envelope I'll get a chance to see your face.
噢，当然。我不记得你的试镜，我也不记得——但我肯定希望当我打开信封时，我会有机会看到你的脸。
Ground zero of my search. Chris Sarson, the producer who rejected me. He's sitting in a studio in Boulder, Colorado, and I'm in a studio in Kentucky.
我寻找的起点。克里斯·萨尔森，那个拒绝我的制作人。他坐在科罗拉多州博尔德市的一个演播室里，我在肯塔基州的一个演播室里。
Why don't you go ahead and open up the envelope I sent you and see if this does any good to jog your memory.
你为什么不打开我寄给你的信封，看看这能不能帮你恢复记忆。
This was awkward.
这很尴尬。
It's like Christmas. Christmas revisited.
就像圣诞节一样。重温圣诞节。
I kind of put him on the spot.
我让他陷入了困境。
Good heavens. I remember you much better now.
天哪。我现在记得你多了。
As I suspected, he didn't really remember who I was, but he was nice about it.
如我所料，他不记得我是谁了，但他表现得很友善。
It's a picture of presumably you, but it doesn't have-- oh, wait a minute, there's a note. This is me--
这是一张可能是你的照片，但没有——噢，等等，有一张便条。这是我——
Obviously this moment was a lot bigger in my life than in his.
显然，这一刻在我的生命中比在他的生命中重要得多。
Well, let me tell you what I recall of what happened and how I came to not be picked for the cast, et cetera. And tell me if this sounds plausible. OK.
好吧，让我告诉你我所记得的发生了什么，以及我如何没被选中参加录制等等。看看这听起来是否合理。好的。
I'm blushing already. I wish we'd picked you!
我已经脸红了。我真希望我们选中了你！
Well, you know, what can you do? This is what I recall.
好吧，你知道，那又能怎样呢？这就是我所记得的。
So I told him what I remembered. And he thought my memory was probably right, but he wasn't sure. And by this time, I've realized it doesn't matter much anyway. And that's incredibly liberating.
所以我告诉了他我的记忆。他认为我的记忆可能是对的，但他不确定。到这个时候，我已经意识到反正也无关紧要了。这让人感到无比解脱。
Correct me if I'm wrong, nobody really went on to a major showbiz career.
如果我错了请纠正我，没有人真正进入了主要的演艺圈。
Well, I think it's lovely where the kids did end up.
嗯，我觉得这些孩子最终的结果很可爱。
Chris told me about the other cast members. Most of them went on to lead a variety of perfectly ordinary lives. None are big stars. One sings with a symphony. There are teachers, doctors, musicians. One was homeless for a while, and some reported having trouble in the aftermath of their brief fame on Zoom .
克里斯告诉了我其他演员的情况。他们大多数人都过着各种各样极其平凡的生活。没有人是大明星。有一个人在交响乐团唱歌。有教师、医生、音乐家。有一个人流浪过一段时间，还有一些人报告说在他们短暂的《Zoom》名气消退后遇到了麻烦。
They were profoundly embarrassed that they'd been on that kid's show, you know, and one guy said that it wasn't until about three or four years ago that he was able to get out and finally admit without shame that he was on the Zoom cast. So it may not have been all rosy if you'd got on the show, Dan.
他们对自己曾经参加那个儿童节目感到非常尴尬，你知道，有一个人说直到三四年前他才能够走出来，最终毫无羞耻地承认他是《Zoom》的成员。所以，丹，如果你参加了那个节目，一切可能并不全是美好的。
OK, I understand that now. I really do. Chances are, it wouldn't have changed my life. But still, I'd take it. That special time, that attention. When all is said and done, I'd take my chances. I'd rather be a Zoom kid than just a kid. Wouldn't you?
好的，我现在明白了。真的。很有可能，它不会改变我的人生。但即便如此，我还是会选择接受。那段特别的时光，那份关注。事后看来，我还是愿意试一试。我宁愿做一个《Zoom》的孩子，而不是普通的平民孩子。你不觉得吗？
But it's OK. I'm still in the game. I write songs now. As a matter of fact, that's me singing one of my original tunes in the background. And I'd like you to know that my tape is available by the way.
但没关系。我还在游戏中。我现在写歌。事实上，背景里唱我原创曲子的就是我。我想让你知道我的磁带顺便说一句是可以买到的。
The name is Dan Gediman, not Danny.
名字是丹·格迪曼，不是丹尼。
Dan Gediman's story was produced by Jay Allison as part of Jay's Life Stories series, which is funded by the Corporation for Public Broadcasting and the National Endowment for the Arts. Coming up, a childhood of lies that may have saved a life. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
丹·格迪曼的故事是由杰伊·艾利森制作的，作为杰伊“生活故事”系列的一部分，该系列由公共广播公司和国家艺术基金会资助。接下来，一个充满谎言的童年可能挽救了一条生命。一分钟后，当我们的节目继续时，请收听国际公共广播电台。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we try to document every day life in these United States. Today's show, Truth and Lies at Age Ten. We've arrived at the second of our two stories, about children who lie to themselves, who lie to others, and who try to stop lying once they get to be adults. Act Two, Truth or Consequences.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，我们每周都在节目中试图记录美国人的日常生活。今天的节目主题是“10岁时的真相与谎言”。我们来到了两个故事中的第二个，关于那些自欺欺人、欺骗他人，并试图在成年后停止撒谎的孩子们。第二幕：真相或后果。
Mary J. Pruka was diagnosed with cystic fibrosis when she was two years old. CF is a degenerative disease that primarily affects the lungs. As your condition worsens your lungs fill with fluid and you have to do hours of respiratory therapy every day to clear out that fluid. Over time it gets so bad that you cannot clear that fluid. Essentially, you drown. Few children with CF live past the age of 18. When Mary Kay was little, understandably, nobody told her that she would die so young. When she went to the doctor, she saw how nervous her mother was. She knew it was something serious.
玛丽·J·普鲁卡在两岁时被诊断出患有囊性纤维化（CF）。CF是一种主要影响肺部的退行性疾病。随着病情的恶化，肺部充满液体，你必须每天进行数小时的呼吸治疗以清理那些液体。随着时间的推移，情况会变得非常糟糕，以至于你无法清理那些液体。本质上，你会淹死。很少有患CF的儿童能活过18岁。当玛丽·凯还小时，理所当然地，没有人告诉她她会这么年轻就死去。当她去看医生时，她看到母亲有多紧张。她知道这是一件严重的事。
But I don't remember myself ever knowing how serious it was or knowing fully what it meant. And I don't think I asked the questions, maybe, that I needed to ask to find out. And I can only assume that maybe I didn't want to know the answers or I just-- I guess that. That I just didn't want to know the answers.
但我自己不记得曾知道它有多严重，或者完全知道这意味着什么。我想我并没有问过那些我需要问的问题来找出答案。我只能假设也许我不想知道答案，或者我只是——我猜是这样。我只是不想知道答案。
I was, I would guess, in the area of about seven years old.
我想，那大约是七岁左右的时候。
Truth and lies at age seven.
7岁时的真相与谎言。
That's when I first learned that CF was a deadly disease. And I had gone off to a CF summer camp for the first time. And I was real nervous about going, but as soon as I got there I felt very comfortable. I was put into a cabin with maybe 12 other girls, and we had a leader whose name was Beth. And I immediately clicked with her, I was her shadow the entire week.
那是我第一次了解到CF是一种致命疾病的时候。我第一次去了一个CF夏令营。我对要去感到非常紧张，但一旦到了那里，我就感到很舒服。我被分配到一个住着大约12个女孩的小屋里，我们有一位领队叫贝丝。我和她一拍即合，整个星期我都是她的影子。
And during the camp we would have an early breakfast, and then afterwards we would go and do respiratory therapy. And at that time, I was not doing respiratory at home on a routine basis. But I noticed that some of the other children at camp needed this. They had to do this every day. And I just kind of sat back and watched. I really didn't feel like I was a participant in that, or that I had the same disease that all these other children had. And so I wasn't forced that first year to really think about why I was there.
在夏令营期间，我们会吃早饭，然后去进行呼吸治疗。当时，我在家里并没有进行常规的呼吸治疗。但我注意到营地里其他一些孩子需要这样做。他们必须每天这样做。我只是坐在后面看。我真的不觉得我是参与者，也不觉得我和其他孩子得的是同一种病。所以第一年我并没有被迫去思考为什么我在那里。
I was very excited to go back. And my first question, when I got there, was where's Beth? She was the one who, the first year, who I palled around with and followed. Here I go. I just remember that she wasn't there. And that they told me that she had died of CF. And I thought, oh my god. You know? I have CF and nobody ever told me I was going to die. And I think a real panic set in.
我非常兴奋能回去。我到达那里的第一个问题是：贝丝在哪里？她是第一年和我形影不离的那个人。我去了那里。我只记得她不在了。他们告诉我她因CF去世了。我心想，噢天哪。你知道吗？我患有CF，但从来没人告诉我我会死。我想一阵真正的恐慌感袭来。
My first thought was, I've got to get out of here. I've got to leave right now and go home. And I remember I just cried. I cried. I didn't tell anybody, I didn't say to anybody, I'm scared, I didn't know that people could die of CF. So it was my aunt and uncle who came and picked me up along with their kids. And they're all saying, you're a baby. Why are you crying to come home?
我的第一个念头是：我得离开这。我得立刻走回家。我记得我只是哭。我哭。我没告诉任何人，我没对任何人说“我害怕，我不知道人们会因为CF而死”。所以我姨妈和姨夫带着他们的孩子来接我。他们都说：“你是个婴儿吗？为什么要哭着回家？”
You know, I really think I believed that if we talked about the possibility that I would die, it could happen. Just saying the words would be enough to make it happen. So even if I got nervous about it, or I had discussions with myself about it, if I didn't verbalize it I would be safe. Or even to say it and let my mom hear it would be even worse. Because I saw that she was afraid of it and she didn't talk about it. So this must be the best way to handle it, is to just not talk about it.
你知道，我真的相信如果我们讨论我可能会死这种可能性，它就真的会发生。只要说出这些词就足以让它发生。所以即使我对此感到紧张，或者我与自己进行了讨论，只要我不把它说出来，我就是安全的。甚至说出来让我妈听到会更糟。因为我看到她是多么害怕它，而且她从不谈论它。所以这一定是处理它的最好方法，就是不谈论它。
I know my parents were devastated by it. I know my mom's initial reaction was that if we just stay positive and maybe not think about it, the bad won't happen. We'll just focus on today and we'll raise her like the other two children. And that was her way of handling it and not thinking about or dealing with the possibility that I might not live long. But my dad and I have never talked about it. I've tried on a number of occasions to have conversations with him about it.
我知道我父母为此伤心欲绝。我知道我妈最初的反应是，如果我们保持积极，也许不去想它，坏事就不会发生。我们只关注今天，我们会像抚养另外两个孩子一样抚养她。这是她处理它的方式，不去想或不去面对我可能活不长的事实。但我父亲和我从未谈论过它。我曾多次尝试和他进行相关对话。
And in my 20s, my CF began to progress, and I began to get worse. And I didn't see my dad very often, so I had a feeling that he didn't know this was happening. And at that point, I began to have frequent hospital stays. And I would call him and say, Dad, I'm in the hospital, for example. And he'd say, oh, OK. And I'd say, well, I'm here for IV therapy. And he'd say, OK, so what else is new? As if there's something else new when you're in the hospital. And I can remember him-- or even changing the subject to, what have your sister and brother been up to?
20多岁时，我的CF开始恶化，我开始变得更糟。我没怎么见到我爸，所以我感觉他不知道发生了什么。在那时，我开始频繁住院。我会打电话告诉他：“爸，我在医院里”。他说：“噢，好的”。我说：“好吧，我在这做静脉注射治疗”。他说：“好的，那有什么新鲜事？”好像住院时还有什么其他新鲜事一样。我记得他甚至会转移话题到“你妹妹和弟弟最近怎么样？”。
Truth and lies at age 15.
15岁时的真相与谎言。
Through the teenage years I think I lived in a fog, like I think a lot of teenagers do. You don't-- you just don't think about the serious life issues that you have to think about. And I think all teenagers think they're invincible. Even when you have a disease, you think you're invincible. Even though you have hard facts in front of you. So I just didn't think about it. I really was able to get away without thinking about it. I really didn't think beyond now. The right now.
在青少年时期，我想我生活在迷雾中，就像我想很多青少年一样。你不会——你只是不去想你不得不面对的严峻生活问题。我认为所有的青少年都认为自己是不可战胜的。即使你患有疾病，你也认为自己是不可战胜的。尽管严酷的事实摆在面前。所以我只是不去想它。我真的能够在不去想它的情况下逃避。我真的没有考虑现在之外的任何事情。此时此刻。
Truth and lies at age 18. At college, for the first time, Mary started to face up to the facts of her situation. And, as it often happens, she was forced into doing this because she faced a crisis in her own life. And what started the crisis was the fact that, for the first time in her life, she was at a place where she had to think about the future. College is about the future. And everybody around Mary Kay had a plan, a purpose, while she had nothing like that. Meanwhile she was getting sicker, having coughing fits more often, and she was starting to change in other ways.
18岁时的真相与谎言。在大学里，玛丽第一次开始直面她的状况。正如经常发生的那样，她被迫这样做，因为她面临着生活中的危机。危机的开始在于，她生命中第一次处于一个必须考虑未来的地方。大学就是关于未来的。每个人周围都有一个计划，一个目标，而她却没有。与此同时她变得越来越虚弱，咳嗽发作得更频繁，并且开始在其他方面发生变化。
But the summer before I went away to Southern Illinois University, I met my husband. And on our first dinner date-- whenever I had a dinner date, or any time I was eating a meal with friends, I had to take my pills. And there was 10 large capsules, so it wasn't anything I could hide at the table. And oftentimes, most times, I would go into the bathroom and take them, so as not to make a scene. And on our first dinner date, I remember boldly taking them out and swallowing them down, knowing that he was going to ask me what I was doing. And I think in some ways I was challenging him. Go ahead. Go ahead and ask me what this means.
但在去南伊利诺伊大学之前的那个夏天，我遇到了我的丈夫。在我们的第一次晚餐约会中——每当我吃晚餐，或者任何时候和朋友一起吃饭时，我都必须吃药。有10颗大胶囊，所以我无法在桌上隐藏。通常，大多数时候，我会去洗手间吃，以免引起注意。而在我们的第一次晚餐约会上，我记得大胆地把它们拿出来吞了下去，知道他会问我在做什么。我想在某种程度上我是在挑战他。来吧。来吧，问我这意味着什么。
And I knew this was going to be, either he was going to accept it and it would be OK. Or it was going to be like past times where no questions were asked, and I got the feeling they didn't want to know anyway, and so we didn't talk about it. And his first reaction was, what is that? And what does that mean? And what is cystic fibrosis? And then that week, he must have asked me 50 questions. And I remember thinking, my god, he's really interested. And he was probably the first person that asked the questions and I answered them. But I think I'd reached a point where I said, I'm not going to pretend this doesn't exist anymore. It's a part of me. This is who I am. And I need to start talking about it.
我知道这要么是他会接受并且一切都会好起来的。要么会像过去一样，没人提问，我觉得他们反正也不想知道，所以我们没谈论它。他的第一反应是：“那是什么？这意味着什么？什么是囊性纤维化？”然后那周，他一定问了我50个问题。我记得我心想：“天哪，他是真的感兴趣。”他可能是第一个问这些问题的人，而我回答了。但我认为我到了一个地步，我说：“我不会再假装它不存在了。它是我的的一部分。这就是我。我需要开始谈论它。”
When I went away to SIU I felt very homesick. And I think I really begin to think, at that point, that I had met somebody who I wanted to spend all of my time with. That I was now wasting precious time that I had, being away at school, that I should be spending with him. And I was beginning to have the sense that I don't know how long I have. And I need to now-- now that I have something that I want to do-- I need to do this and I need to leave school.
当我去SIU时，我感到很想家。我想在那个时候我真的开始认为，我遇到了一个我想共度所有时间的人。我正在浪费我拥有的宝贵时间，离开学校去我应该和他一起度过的地方。我开始有一种感觉，我不知道我还有多少时间。我需要现在——既然我有了我想做的事情——我需要去做这些，我需要离开学校。
But something else happened during this time. This is something that may be very minor for some people, but this was a really big deal for me, is that I got braces during this time. And for me that was a big, big step in planning for the future. Because I remember thinking-- it was a big expense-- and for me, it was the first time that I really took on an expense for myself. And I remember thinking to myself, now, am I going to die in a couple years anyway? And this is the biggest purchase I had ever made. And I thought, do I really want to get braces and invest all of this into my-- you know, into my teeth and into my looks? And how long am I really going to live anyway? And just getting-- in just making that decision and deciding to go ahead and get braces, for me, it meant that I had enough confidence in the future, even if it only meant the next five to seven years. I had to sort of weigh, well, if I live only five years, will it be worth the investment? And I thought, yeah, it's worth the investment.
但在这段时间里还发生了别的事情。这对某些人来说可能非常微不足道，但这对我来说是一件大事，就是我在那段时间戴了牙套。对我来说，那是规划未来的重要一步。因为我记得我当时想——这是一个很大的开支——对我来说，这是我第一次真正为自己承担开支。我记得心想：“我会几年后就死吗？”这是我买过的最贵的东西。我想，“我真的想戴牙套并把所有这些投资在我的牙齿和外表上吗？我真的还能活多久？”在那个决策和决定继续进行时，对我来说，这意味着我对未来有足够的信心，即使它只意味着未来五到七年。我必须权衡一下，“嗯，如果我只活五年，这个投资值得吗？”我想，“是的，值得。”
My health was starting to decline. It was starting to now become something I had to think about every day. And amazingly, at that time, John decided that he was going to be the person to do my respiratory therapy every day. And in order to do respiratory therapy, the object is to loosen the secretions in my lungs. And as the disease progresses, my lungs begin to fill up with fluid every day. And if I didn't get the fluid out I couldn't breathe.
我的健康开始下降。它开始变成我每天必须考虑的事情。令人惊讶的是，在那时，约翰决定成为每天给我进行呼吸治疗的人。为了进行呼吸治疗，目的是松动肺部的分泌物。随着疾病的进展，我的肺部每天开始充满液体。如果我不把液体排出来，我就无法呼吸。
And so what he would do is he would just get behind me and start to pound on my back at the different lobes of my lungs. And that would loosen the secretions. And then by using his hands on my back, in a sort of vibration, I could then cough out the secretions. And there's nothing pretty about it. It's very disgusting. And this is just something that you can't imagine couples sharing. Or you would think if you met somebody, you would be embarrassed to involve them in, in respiratory therapy.
所以他会做的是站在我身后，开始敲打我背部肺部的不同叶片。这会松动分泌物。然后通过他在我背上的手，以一种震动的方式，我可以咳出分泌物。这没什么美感。非常恶心。这是你无法想象伴侣会分享的事情。或者你会认为如果你遇到某人，你会因为让他们参与呼吸治疗而感到尴尬。
But when we finished doing the respiratory therapy, and I could breathe better, he felt better. And it is-- it is very intimate. We would sometimes joke about it. We were forced to spend this time together. If we had had an argument five minutes earlier, it had to be done and over with, because I needed to breathe. And so we called it our therapy. Besides being respiratory therapy, our couple therapy. And it was intimate and that it would bring us together. And we were forced to sit and do this.
但当我们做完呼吸治疗，我可以呼吸得更好时，他感觉也更好。这真的很亲密。我们有时会开玩笑。我们被迫花这段时间在一起。如果我们五分钟前吵了一架，那也必须做完并结束，因为我需要呼吸。所以我们称之为我们的治疗。除了呼吸治疗，我们夫妇的治疗。这很亲密，因为它会让我们靠在一起。我们被迫坐下来做这件事。
We got engaged when we were both 23 years old. We had been dating now for four years. And this was a big, big step for me. Getting engaged. And we had a great wedding. I was terrified the whole day. I was just very nervous. Because this meant so much. It meant that I believed I was going to have a future. And it meant that for everybody in the room, and everybody in the church, that they believed I believed I had a future. And I wondered, how many people behind me are doubting? Are thinking I'm kidding myself? I was always afraid people thought I was kidding myself. And I even wondered, am I kidding myself? Or who am I fooling, to think that I'm going to get married today and have a whole future ahead?
我们在23岁时订婚了。我们已经约会了四年。这对我来说是很大很大的一步。订婚。我们举办了一场盛大的婚礼。整天我都吓坏了。我只是非常紧张。因为这意味着太多了。这意味着我相信我会有未来。这意味着在房间里的每个人，和教堂里的每个人，他们相信我相信我有未来。我想，我身后有多少人在怀疑？在想我在自欺欺人吗？我总是害怕人们认为我在自欺欺人。我甚至怀疑，“我是在自欺欺人吗？或者我在糊弄谁，觉得我今天结婚以后会有完整的未来？”
I had one really bad episode at the reception. And that was, I was having increased trouble breathing around this time. And I had just begun having episodes of hemoptysis. And that is when bleeding starts in the lungs and you start to just cough up blood and choke on blood. And during the reception I was dancing and there was a bunch of people dancing. And we were actually playing a game of musical chairs and the men were all the chairs. They were getting down on one knee so the women could sit on their knee. And this was kind of happening like a musical chairs game. And just as the game was over, I had the real familiar cough. And I started to feel my chest filling with blood. And it's just a horrifying feeling of panic. And I knew what was going to happen. I had a white gown on and I just ran to the bathroom. And started coughing up blood. And so that kind of just changed the whole mood then of the day for me. Because that was-- this was the one day that I was not going to think about CF, and there it was, right in my face.
在招待会上我发生了一次很严重的状况。那是，在那段时间我呼吸困难加剧。我刚开始出现咯血的发作。那是肺部开始出血，你开始咳血并被血窒息的时候。在招待会上我正在跳舞，有一群人在跳舞。我们其实正在玩抢椅子游戏，男人们全是椅子。他们单膝跪地，女人们可以坐在他们的膝盖上。这就像一个抢椅子游戏。就在游戏结束后，我有了非常熟悉的咳嗽感。我开始觉得胸部充满了血。这是一种极度恐怖的恐慌感。我知道会发生什么。我穿着白色的婚纱，直接跑向洗手间。开始咳血。所以那确实改变了那天我对这一天的全部情绪。因为那是——这是我原本不打算考虑CF的一天，但它却直接出现在我面前。
Truth and lies at age 24. Mary Kay's health deteriorated. Her lungs were failing. She tried to get answers about her condition from her doctor who only told her not to worry. So ready to face the truth, she got another doctor, one who told her that she was in the final stages of the disease. It was a rather jolting dose of reality. Mary Kay told her mother that she hated her new doctor, would never see the new doctor again. This feeling didn't last. Mary Kay started to investigate more aggressive treatments for CF with her doctor.
24岁时的真相与谎言。玛丽·凯的健康状况恶化了。她的肺部在衰竭。她试图从医生那里得到关于病情的答案，医生只是告诉她不用担心。准备面对真相，她找了另一位医生，一位告诉她她处于疾病最后阶段的医生。这是一剂相当令人震惊的现实剂量。玛丽·凯告诉她妈妈，她讨厌这位新医生，再也不会见他了。这种感觉没持续多久。玛丽·凯开始与她的医生研究针对CF更积极的治疗方法。
Finally, at the age of 30, Mary Kay was in her kitchen reaching for a glass and suddenly she began choking and coughed up a bowl of blood. When doctors tried to operate, she had a stroke on the operating table. They signed her up for a lung transplant, which they only do if they think you don't have much longer to live. Mary Kay waited 13 months for a donor.
最终，30岁时，玛丽·凯在厨房伸手去拿杯子，突然开始窒息，吐出了一盆血。当医生试图动手术时，她在手术台上中风了。他们为她安排了肺移植，只有在他们认为你活不长时才会这样做。玛丽·凯等待了13个月才等到捐赠者。
I remember Christmas time in December that I really began to think that this really, really might be my last Christmas. And I really had an awful Christmas. I spent the day-- I spent the day imagining next Christmas and my family not having me there. And I couldn't help imagining this picture without me. And what would it be like? And what would my family be like? And how would they handle my death.
我记得12月的圣诞节，我真的开始认为这可能真的是我最后一个圣诞节了。我度过了一个糟糕的圣诞节。我花了一整天想象下一个圣诞节，而我的家人没有我在场。我忍不住想象没有我的画面。会是什么样？我的家人会是什么样？他们会如何处理我的死亡？
I had finally had a conversation with my mom. And I told her that I was afraid to die. And she said, I know. And she hugged me. And that was a big moment for us. Because we had never-- she knew I was afraid, and this was our fear all along. And we had never really verbalized it. And we were just standing in my bedroom and she was helping me get dressed or something like that. And I just said, you know, this disease just might get me. I really thought I might beat it, but I don't know anymore.
我最终和我妈谈过了。我告诉她我害怕死亡。她说：“我知道。”她拥抱了我。这对我们来说是一个伟大的时刻。因为我们从来没谈过——她知道我害怕，这就是我们一直以来的恐惧。我们从未真正说出口。我们当时只是站在我的卧室里，她正在帮我穿衣服之类的。我只是说：“你知道，这种病可能会夺走我。我真的以为我可能会打败它，但我不知道了。”
And she just said, we just have to get those lungs. We just have to keep praying for those lungs. And so that's what we did. And I just-- we just hoped all the time. Every time I watched the news, I would-- it sounds really terrible-- but I would hear of an accident and I would think, you know, that's really a shame. But I wonder if they'll donate the organs. And you feel terrible thinking that way. And I remember my mom telling me that she had thoughts like that. And she felt terribly guilty after thinking that. But I spent a lot of time preoccupied with death during that time.
她只是说：“我们必须得到那些肺。我们必须继续为那些肺祈祷。”所以我们就这么做了。我只是——我们一直都在希望。每次我看新闻，我都会——这听起来真的很糟糕——但我会听到一场事故，我会心想，“你知道，这真的很遗憾。但我不知道他们是否会捐献器官。”你这样想会感到很糟糕。我记得我妈告诉我她也有过那样的想法。她在想完后感到极其愧疚。但我在那段时间里花了很多时间沉浸在对死亡的沉思中。
Truth and lies at age 31. After 13 months, Mary Kay got her transplant. She said that she had never experienced before this what it was like to be healthy. She did not even know how to imagine what it was going to be like. Suddenly she could breathe. The purpose of her life was no longer simply staying alive. Now she's 33 years old. Since her transplant, she's had two children, twin girls. And though one of the central struggles of her life has been to learn to face the truth about her own disease, she says there is a time and place for lying to yourself.
31岁时的真相与谎言。13个月后，玛丽·凯接受了移植手术。她说她在那之前从未经历过健康是什么样。她甚至不知道该如何想象它会是什么样。突然她可以呼吸了。她生活的目的不再仅仅是维持生命。现在她33岁了。自移植以来，她生了两个孩子，双胞胎女孩。虽然她一生中的核心斗争之一就是学习直面自己疾病的真相，但她说自欺欺人也有它的时间和地点。
About the age of 10, I don't think I was very honest with myself about the illness that I had. I honestly don't think I would have it differently at that point. I sometimes wonder what my life would have been like if I had been told early on that I was probably going to die at the age of, you know, in my teen years, for example. Which is, I believe, what my mother was being told at that time. I think that news in itself can be crippling. And because I wasn't feeling the effects of the disease yet, I don't believe I needed to know it then. But I have to look back and wonder if the fact that I did so well has something to do with the ignorance that I had at that time.
大约10岁时，我不认为我对自己的疾病非常诚实。老实说，我不认为我会在那个时候有什么不同。我有时想知道，如果我早点被告知我可能在十几岁时就会死去，比如我妈当时被告知的那样，我的生活会是什么样。我想那种消息本身就是瘫痪性的。而且因为我当时还没感受到疾病的影响，我不相信我当时需要知道它。但我必须回顾过去，想知道我表现得那么好是否与我当时那种无知有关。
Mary J. Pruka, she spoke with reporter Adam Davidson.
玛丽·J·普鲁卡，她接受了记者亚当·戴维森的采访。
Well, our program was produced today by Julie Snyder and myself, with Alix Spiegel and Nancy Updike. [UNINTELLIGIBLE] editor, Paul Tough. Contributing editors, Jack Hitt, [? Margie Rocklin, ?] and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from [? Sylvia Leemis, ?] [UNINTELLIGIBLE] [? Davenport ?], and [? Laura ?] [? Doggett ?], who interviewed Claire, the non-Chilean woman at the beginning of our broadcast.
好吧，我们今天的节目是由朱莉·斯奈德和我自己制作的，还有阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克。[难以理解]编辑，保罗·托夫。特约编辑，杰克·希特，[？玛吉·罗克林，？]以及顾问萨拉·沃威尔。制作协助来自[？西尔维娅·利米斯，？][难以理解][？达文波特，？]以及[？劳拉·多格特，？]她采访了克莱尔，即广播开头那位非智利籍女子。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
［致谢］
Dan Gediman has asked us to mention that his CD can be purchased at 1-800-BUY-MYCD. And we would like to take a moment to point out that Mary Kay Pruka's life was saved, and she had two beautiful baby girls who are actually here in our studio today, only because somebody signed the organ donor release on the back of their driver's license. We don't usually say this kind of the thing on the show, but I would urge you to consider taking out your license right this second and signing up right now.
丹·格迪曼要求我们提一下他的CD可以在1-800-BUY-MYCD购买。我们想花点时间指出，玛丽·凯·普鲁卡的生命得到了挽救，她有两个美丽的女儿，她们今天就坐在我们的演播室里，这仅仅是因为有人在驾照背面签署了器官捐赠授权书。我们通常不会在节目中说这种话，但我强烈建议你现在就拿出驾照，现在就签上名。
If you want to buy a cassette of our program, you can call us here at WBEZ in Chicago. 312-832-3380. 312-832-3380. Our email address, [email protected] . Or you know you can listen to nearly all of our shows for free on the internet, www.thislife.org.
如果你想购买我们节目的磁带，你可以打我们的电话，地址是芝加哥的WBEZ，312-832-3380。312-832-3380。我们的电子邮件地址是[email protected]。或者你知道，你可以免费在互联网上收听我们几乎所有的节目，www.thislife.org。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
［资助方名单］
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia who walks into our studio after each and every show with this request.
WBEZ的管理监督是托里·马拉蒂亚，他在每场节目结束后都会走进我们的演播室提出这个要求。
You're not asked this very often, I'm wondering if you could autograph your picture here.
你不太常被这样要求，我想知道你能不能在这张照片上签名。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再见，会有更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。